I know how many times have you seen this
blue shirt it's laundry day don't judge
me
a day you sell lost episode huh Oh what
is going on YouTube there are some
things that I have done in my life that
I'm not too proud of
maybe this episode right here I told
myself I would release this but I think
y'all deserve to see this whenever in
the gamma will not put on knees together
something happens and uh user turns out
to be a hot mess originally this video
was supposed to be a simple workout
weight loss video and then uh shake on
out of hand so before you go ahead uh
stop judging me on their certain parts
in this video that came up um little
creepy
don't judge me it's all in the name of
comedy and um you're ready Jenny I can
tell I don't even want to eat just watch
the clip
so I got a call this morning and um
least uh I was a little excited to hear
that artichoke wants to meet me
um she's a fan of my work do I know who
she is
I might you know who might like this
piece of information
Nagappa are Nichelle's gonna be my video
that's right
who's Rho C you don't have a listen to
when I talk to you see that's the damn
problem so you don't know Warren Cho is
you know yeah she's a celebrity you
think I should lose some weight
see this is exactly what we got promised
because you never listen to it no no no
I'm gonna punch in your face how about
that you know what come over to this
let's go
in retrospect I think I should lose some
weight maybe clean myself up a little
bit uh I don't think I looked at that um
I made gained a few pounds and in the
you know in the past you know four or
five months but doesn't mean that I'm
not beautiful right
get the part getting ready to go got my
fit ready the couple said he's gonna
train me today so I kind of don't know
what he has in store for me but I'm
ready let's do this
I'm ready go
what are you wearing for Japan
you look like a mall Walker if the
middle of May take your sweater off
why you so picky about the stuff that
I'm where it's not about on gear okay
put this sweater back on you look up
booze cruise
everything here's a lot less fuel me
moving fast we move it fast up the
McGraw's
up slide down the slide gonna be coming
on everything okay all right we're gonna
do everything and you'll be slim looking
nice part okay
lop sweet go pump those legs huh come on
come on my grandma put punch back come
on and she did the legs okay
okay lovers love get up love but you
don't get up move this right here is
gonna be amazing for your arms gonna be
able to get old bison hold on a second
I think use the woodchips and lava how
come you're not burning them lava
shooters not for anyway so I'm going to
skip it every other bars swinging crop
like you little monkey like us poop and
see me I can't do that you can do it do
you believe yourself if endo hair David
if yet don't mess with the big cell I
believe in you go
okay I'm believing a bird get up all
right I want you going underneath
all right underneath like golden pipes
go fetch all right
then you'll give me some birth don't
give silver all right go far go far is
that your lady let speed date today
see they go but still do but still do
Bradley their crab leg damn crab legs
all the way down
oh hi David we're at a competitive edge
to this whole exciting you and me right
here chicken fight okay no we're not
doing chicken fight we're done today
come on look jump do know the suit is
for our meal okay let's go give you that
upper body strength that you need don't
add a competitive edge
let's go be perfect it's all meant to
munagi okay let's deal I don't even know
Dave all three on three ready six three
Garlan victory I feel it's not okay
let's go baby it's good no pain no gain
that's how work hurry up okay we only
got a couple and got a couple more
workouts left okay this next one is
gonna be perfect this is a unique thing
out developed over years all right gonna
chime you in a beast one channel all
right we'll go this your right after
like you've never ran before in your
life
ready [ __ ] no all right so we're gonna
do tumble all right let's go my heart
rate coordination let me just like all
those little asian girls in China skin
you know leotard i swatched your
continuous colors over and over tumblr
card with cartwheels cartwheels coffee
truth is the Gobbo and Ziggler
schoolyard workout all made up that
fetch thing almost let me die fry in the
middle come on baby come on like China
like China keep moving cartwheel baby
sorry I'll call will I don't think this
one those weights do I think he just
getting back at me for all the racist
jokes I've been making that him to be
told I'm trying to get back at him for
making all those black jokes give it it
baby
cartwheel no no no no yeah lava the
grass blah a cartwheel of them
it's Palmero discard the elements the
wind blows
the grass grows dead between my toes
the streets have many hoes thank you